if you look at a lot of ancient
civilizations they worshipped the sharks
they were like their gods but then some
silly movies came out creating
fictitious stories about
sharks that have territories and are
lurking around for people
and we know from our work that is just
not the case
hey everybody chris fisher here founding
chairman of osearch
we're preparing to head out on our 38th
expedition in new england
to tag and track great white sharks in
an effort to make sure they have a
bright future and there's lots of food
in the atlantic ocean for our grandkids
i'm here to debunk some ocean myths
the ocean can absorb anything the ocean
is
absorbing a lot of things that we put
into the environment co2
a lot of plastic and it definitely has a
finite ability to be able to handle all
the stuff we're throwing at it one of
the biggest misconceptions we face
around this
is the concept of these gyres in the
ocean or the pacific garbage patch
in fact there are five gyres around the
world in the ocean that are all
collecting debris
now people think you're gonna drive out
there and you're gonna see an island
full of garbage
that's simply not the case so you got to
think about it more like
a big swirling bowl of pea soup
and the capacity to clean that up has
not been discovered yet
because the plastic is so small and it
is so vast that filtering it out
would require filtering out all the life
that's in the ocean in that area
as well and it's tough to just grab and
get it out of the water we got real
problems when it comes to plastics and
this is something
every single one of us can contribute to
the solution
no more single-use plastic bottles look
after your plastic
make sure it's recycled and make sure it
stays on land and i hate to be the
downer
but no more balloons at the birthday
parties
we find them scattered all over the
ocean when they get free from people
they drift out
end up on the ocean and then a poor
turtle thinks it's something like it can
eat
and it does bad things to turtles and
ends up polluting the future
plastic is one of the single biggest
threats to the future of the ocean
sharks are better dead than alive
replace that fear with facts
sharks are the key to the future
abundance of the ocean
they prevent the second tier the food
chain from exploding and wiping out all
the fish we need to eat an apex predator
is the top of the food chain they
prevent the second tier of the food
chain from running wild and consuming
everything below them so
everything is connected and the apex
predator sets the tone for the system
when you lose that predator you lose the
system white sharks have been around for
millions of years
how have they survived that long how
have they evolved
to heal wounds rapidly because they have
very violent lives
we're doing a lot of work on the ship
where we take the bacteria off white
sharks and we're developing
new antibiotics for things like staph
and mrsa
not many things have survived on earth
for millions of years
and if we can learn how they've done
that it could have tremendous
medical benefits for humans the bermuda
triangle
is an actual phenomenon i don't know
what's going on there we've spent a
little bit of time in that waters on the
edges of the bermuda triangle and we've
never seen anything happen but there
seems to be too many crazy stories
over too long a period of time to not
wonder about what's going on in the
bermuda triangle
maybe it's beyond all of what we know
and there is no
natural explanation sharks can smell
blood from a mile away
we work on the ocean all over the world
if it were that easy to attract sharks
we would have them swimming right up to
our research ship
and we will be able to tag as many as we
like quickly for our science teams
most of the time when there's a shark
human interaction it's just mistaken
identity because we put on a wetsuit and
we're swimming with seals and we fool
them
once they realize they've touched the
wrong thing they swim off
so being worried about sharks or a shark
interaction
is something that doesn't really make
any sense if you're going down to the
ocean and you're wondering if sharks are
around
it's a very simple thing to figure out
take a look at the ocean
if there's a lot of birds diving on bait
and there's game fish eating the bait
and there's seals and dolphins eating
those game fish the sharks are going to
be there
the food chain is going off right before
your very eyes
there's plenty of fish in the sea
unfortunately it is
totally possible to overfish the ocean
as we've developed
bigger and bigger scale around our
fishing operations
we are seeing the type of gear that can
absolutely wipe out
fish stocks with the development of
super long lines
mega trawlers and massive saining nets
we now know we do have the capacity to
tap the ocean out
at a level beyond which it can reproduce
itself
just to give you an idea on how this
works what you're going for
is sustainability that means we harvest
enough food
for people to eat but we leave enough
fish
in the water that they can make more
fish so we can do the same thing the
following year
now there's certain species that it's
easier to do that with but if you think
about a white shark if you start taking
any of those they have to live
20 years before they can have babies
this type of animal
can't handle any pressure because it
doesn't live
long enough to replace itself if you're
over harvesting it
there's lots of good ways to restore
fish populations number one we can use
things like
slot limits you can only catch fish of a
certain size that means you can't catch
the babies and you can't catch the big
ones the funniest thing about fishing is
people always want to go out and catch
the big one
that's not the one you want to take home
oftentimes that's not the one that even
tastes the best
you want to let the big ones go that's
our brood stock they make lots of babies
if you want to take one home for your
family take a nice small one home
anytime you over fish one species of
fish in the food web
it affects everything because it's all
connected
you over fish one species the thing that
they used to eat maybe it was jellyfish
explode in numbers because nothing's
eating them anymore then you end up with
an
ocean full of jellyfish the idea that
there's an unlimited amount of fish and
we can't overfish it in the ocean
might have been true a hundred years ago
but it is no longer true today
the great barrier reef is dead while the
great barrier reef
is struggling there are many many people
doing great work to help restore it one
of the things you'll see when you see a
dead reef is it lacks all the colors it
lacks all the life
when you see an abundant reef like a
place like ningaloo reef
off of northwestern australia it's full
of colors full of fishes of all size
there are also marine mammals it is
possible to bring the reefs back there's
great projects in florida bringing back
the coral reefs of the keys
and there's great projects in australia
doing the same thing and the great
barrier reef
one of the things we should all do if we
want to help out our coral reefs around
the world is make sure we use
reef friendly sunscreen these sunscreens
don't have any chemicals in it that will
hurt the reef
whales can hear each other from
thousands of miles away
one thing we do know is whales do have
the capacity to communicate across
very large areas
different whale species have different
sounds that they make and sometimes they
can determine
by a given sound what individual of that
species it is
like humans they all got their own tone
and their own story to tell
the ocean is largely unexplored much of
the very deep of the ocean is
unexplored but there are lots of parts
of the ocean that have been well
explored
especially those parts that are around
the surface so you got to think about
the ocean
almost like you think about land there
are mountains in the ocean there are
valleys in the ocean there are rivers in
the ocean some of our great currents
like the gulf stream
or the agullas current in africa the
seafloor is not flat when you go down to
the ocean bottom you have all sorts of
different structures you have
continental shelves that drop
off into the ocean abyss there are
mountain ranges
everywhere valleys throughout the bottom
of the ocean there are certainly a lot
of species that are yet to be discovered
in the ocean
most of which are in the very deep deep
ocean but don't get all
carried away there's no giant creatures
down there like a megalodon or something
else that you might see in the movies
you can swim against a rip current well
while you might be able to swim against
a rip current you're probably not going
to make it back to shore you're just
going to get real tired and washed out
to sea
rip currents are really dangerous if you
spend a little time looking at the ocean
before you can get in
you can avoid them most all the time but
if you get caught up in one don't swim
against the current
swim across it until you come out of it
and then swim on into the beach
a rip current or a riptide is when two
currents collide on the beach
and then they both turn against each
other and push straight out to sea
it's very very powerful and they're
typically not that wide it's like a
little
narrow river shooting out into the ocean
right off the beach because
of the collision of these two currents
most of the time
you can see rip currents from the beach
when the two currents maybe one coming
down the beach and one coming up
collide they both bend off each other
and push out to sea
most of the time when you see that
they're sucking out a lot of sand and
there's also sometimes foam in the water
remember when you head to the ocean that
once you're two or three feet
into the water you are deep into the
wilderness
so make sure you look at the ocean if
you see a lot of jellyfish you may want
to avoid that area
if there's huge waves and rip currents
not a good place to go swimming and even
if there's just a lot of bait seals and
birds diving
there's likely going to be sharks in
that area look for quiet places where
the waves aren't too big
and there's not a lot of life in the
area thanks so much for tuning in to
mythbusting
remember we're just passengers on this
planet
and the ocean is the primary regulator
of our planet and all the fish and
animals that live in it
they are the crew they are maintaining
the very system that we all depend on to
live
let's be responsible passengers and
let's make sure all our great
grandchildren and future generations
have a smooth ride as well and that's
only going to happen
with a clean ocean that's full of fish